[Music]
recently you were at Sundance with
American ham this is quite a prestigious
opportunity I would think a prestigious
occasion to present your thoughts at the
Sundance it was it's a concert film of
my American ham show and it was very
flattering
I was not surprised though that they
wanted to show American ham because I
know what the secret ingredients are
that every film needs to get into
Sundance you know the you know the
secret formula that if any independent
film follows it they will be accepted at
Sundance I do yeah it might it might be
easier to explain to you using the power
of song oh okay
conveniently located yeah it's always
there in case anyone needs it okay this
is how you get into Sundance now some
very important business before we can
proceed and if this secret gets out to
the world it just might cause a stampede
the ingredients that make indie films
the coolest of the breed are simply weed
and some legalized herbal remedy will
help the judges to proceed especially if
you're leading lassies are notably loose
need the quality of your indie film will
be impossible to miss read if you got
some weed and and weed weed and and we
nice
[Applause]